et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre picard docteur en géopolitique et
en géographie humaine à l'université
paris 8 spécialiste de la chine bonsoir
pierre picard merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur rt france plusieurs pays on l'a
vu pointe un manque de transparence qui
aurait pu jouer notamment sur la
propagation du virus je rappelle qu'il
ya plus de deux millions de personnes
infectées et plus de 140 et remis morts
à travers le monde
pourquoi ces critiques aujourd'hui
envers la chine selon vous alors il est
sûr que la chine a essuyé les plâtres
il n'est pas pour autant indiquer
qu'elle n'a pas eu un quelconque retard
dans la gestion de cette crise
mais la chine surtout à la suite du
strass a fait vraiment un effort
considérable en matière de coopération
internationale
et aujourd'hui elle appelle l'ensemble
des pays à coopérer alors bien
évidemment il peut y avoir des querelles
sur les chiffres nous le savons nous
mêmes qui avons connu de par le passé
des problèmes sanitaires avec décrivent
de chaleur on peut réajuster les choses
globalement on fera les comptes après
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui la chine
est vraiment déterminée en tout cas
c'est mon opinion à avoir un impact de
transparence au regard de la communauté
internationale et surtout de coopérer
pour régler l'ensemble des problèmes
alors par contre on a observé une jeu
direct une relative bonne gestion en
europe de la crise sanitaire en prenant
d'ailleurs soin de l'expérience chinoise
ou d'autres pays comme l'italie
mais par contre il faut quand même
regretter aujourd'hui que les états unis
aient perdu ou d'autres pays d'ailleurs
et perdu pratiquement deux mois où 70
jours pour mettre en oeuvre des mesures
efficaces et et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a l'impression quelque part
qu aujourd'hui on a une suite de la
guerre économique que washington engagé
peu ou prou avec l'europe ou avec la vie
aujourd'hui il faut plutôt lutter contre
je dirais ce racisme qui consiste à dire
il ya un virus y voir un virus n'est
jamais chinois c'est un virus qui a eu
une origine scientifique
il faut lutter contre les comportements
je dirais anti asiatique est aujourd'hui
se rassembler dans une coopération
internationale et je pense qu'il faut
deviennent au contraire lorsque nous
allons rouvrir nos frontières ne ne plus
continuer à fermer nos économies a fermé
la frontière comme l'ont fait notamment
les états unis en nous privant d'une
politique économique en asie et en
europe notamment
on avait également des plus que du
racisme y avait également des vols des
vols de matériaux sanitaire de
différents pays alors qu'aujourd'hui
l'heure n'est pas la discorde mis au
rassemblement international
alors comment vous expliquer notamment
les critiques les plus vives qui
viennent notamment des états unis qui
ont émis des doutes sur l'origine de la
pandémie
certains disent que ça viendrait d'un
d'un laboratoire chinois de yoann c'est
quoi ces politiques les états unis
veulent désigner un coupable cette crise
vous savez c'est essayer de je dirais
dans la nature humaine
je crois que quand il ya une crise
importante au niveau d'un groupe
communautaire au niveau d'un pays ou du
monde ont il est plus facile de trouver
un coupable
maintenant pour les électeurs ou
également parce que c'est je dirais un
petit peu le cerveau reptilien akili
bomba il faut trouver il faut trouver un
coupable un virus de ce que je sais je
ne suis pas un scientifique
les gens disent que si le virus a été
créé par l'homme il y aurait une forme
de deux signatures dans le code
génétique est aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
articles scientifiques que j'ai pu lire
indique que bien évidemment l'homme n'a
pas pu fabriquer ces virus puisqu'en
fait le séquençage montrerait qu'il y
ait une présence une intervention de
l'homme dont ce virus donc il s'agit
bien je dirais de la continuité de la
vie elle même c'est à dire de la
transformation des virus qui peuvent
passer on le sait très bien par des
animaux
familier par des animaux sauvages et ce
virus ne devrait pas être en tout cas
l'oeuvre de tirer du docteur
frankenstein ou d'un laboratoire
donc aujourd'hui c'est sans les
scientifiques qui vont parler demain
mais à ce jour l'ensemble des des
articles internationaux digne de ce nom
disco effectivement il n'y a pas eu en
tout cas et c'est sera approuvée bien
sûr mais qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'intervention humaine
donc je pense la france un parent par la
voix d'emmanuel macron dans une
interview au financial times dit à avoir
des doutes également la france qui on
sait a reçu des commandes de masques de
la part de la chine la chine qui s'est
également montré critique sur la gestion
de la crise en france donc ça met à mal
la vie des opérations justement en
matière sanitaire c'est ces querelles
politiques je ne le pense pas je pense
que quand il ya une crise économique on
a le droit d'être parfois en désaccord
on a le droit de critiquer on peut avoir
confiance et on peut en même temps
contrôler on peut poser question
et le président m'a cran a toute sa
légitimité à poser les questions comme
le chinois comme les américains les
autres l'essentiel c'est que demain on
arrive à je dirais une transparence
totale et c'est transparent je pense que
la chine est prête à la donner pour que
effectivement non seulement on lutte
contre le corona virus et ayant le coc
vie de 21 mais aussi tu l'on trouve je
dirais un système international pour
lutter contre l'ensemble des crises dans
le monde sanitaire économique et
financière et là on a un magnifique en
jeu on a une position chinoise mais
également d'autres pays qui sont prêts à
coopérer mais bien évidemment toutes les
questions qui sont posées sur la table
sans légitime et il faudra que nous tous
nous essayons d'y répondre mais dans la
franchise pas dans le combat et pas en
désignant de prime abord un coupable
vous parlez d'un instrument il ya
également l' oms inquiets critiquer qui
est elle même accusée d'être
l'instrument
la chine s'est justifié selon vous
écoutez je pense que c'est totalement
injustifiée mais pourquoi accuser un
organisme international fussent le nu
fut selon msf suisse une autre
organisation d'être comme je le disais
tout à l'heure le coupable de nos
misères non par rapport à cette
situation il nous faut comment les nous
mêmes en france
comment les nous-mêmes entre européens
travailler avec l'ensemble des pays et
trouver des solutions à la fois pour
vaincre ce virus est également
construire un monde meilleur
ça veut dire aussi que demain nous
aurons à affronter ensemble une crise
économique et financière
il faudra qu'elle soit la plus douce
possible il faudra peut-être baisser les
taxes commerciales entre les pays pour
redonner confiance à l'économie
donc il faut avoir un regard positif il
faut arrêter aujourd'hui de désigner à
l'avancé le coupable mais travailler
ensemble dans une coopération
internationale merci beaucoup pierre
picard d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france